americans are still buying new cars and
light trucks the demand is strong that's
despite the economic uncertainty in this
country right now but the car people are
buying it may change in the years to
come the auto industry is accelerating a
shift to electric vehicles and general
motors the country's largest automaker
plans to have 40 percent of its vehicles
electric by the end of 2025 just around
the corner only on cbs mornings gm chair
and ceo mary barra is here to reveal the
next big step in that process uh thank
you for being here mary i appreciate it
um i want to get to the big reveal a lot
of people want to see what's going to be
underneath that you're going to re the
tarp is going to get pulled the curtain
will be off but i have to ask because a
lot of people were worried about that
recession the economic uncertainty from
what you're seeing internally are you
concerned you might be releasing a new
car into a country that is going to be
suffering economically well you know
we're watching everything very carefully
we're still seeing strong demand because
there's pent-up demand for for autos
right now so we're seeing that but i
think what makes it so special for the
chevrolet equinox it's affordable
vehicle it's in the you know the biggest
segment over 20
of people buy a car in this vehicle or a
crossover i should say in this size so
we're and it's it's going to be
affordable around 30 thousand dollars
that's really in the sweet spot for the
new car market so we think this vehicle
is going to really change people's minds
about electric vehicles wait so you
buried the news there so the equinox is
what's underneath the uh the current are
you gonna can we see it yeah
let's take a look it's under the silk
under the silver what do you call that
what's the industry term
there we go that's gorgeous oh i'm very
cool super excited about it and you can
see so to have this type of vehicle and
it's got technology safety it's got a
over a 17-inch screen inside supercruise
is available on it which is the
industry-leading uh driver assistance
technology so this is a vehicle that is
going to surprise and delight customers
and again it's i'm struck by that price
because i was talking a friend the other
day and he said i can't find anything
for less than forty five thousand
dollars i'm going to send them your
number
do you see what we showed on cbs
mornings what excites you most about
this car okay the price is really i
think very appealing for a lot of people
well i think because we've invested we
started in 2018 working on a a
purpose-built platform for evs called
altium that allows us to do everything
from a uh
suv or a crossover this size all the way
to a super truck like the hummer we're
getting that efficiency by reusing parts
we also have made the decision to uh
build cells in this country and we our
first plant just came online a couple
weeks ago and so when you have the
vertical integration when you have a
scalable platform it allows you to bring
vehicles to market at you know around
thirty thousand dollars that are going
to be affordable
and profitable are you saying that elon
musk move over were you all looking to
see what he and saw what he was doing
and said we need to get in this market
did he have anything to do with that
well you know we have been on the
journey from evs uh actually for over
two decades we started with ev1 we think
we were a little ahead of our time the
chevrolet bolt has been out uh and it it
is a very in fact last month we had a
sales record and so you know we've been
in the in the eevee
business for quite a while but we really
have seen a tipping point and that's why
general motors made the commitment that
by 2020 or 2035 all of our light duty
vehicles in the u.s will be electric
because we want to lead from a full-line
manufacturer perspective and leverage
you know the thing by 2035 like 2030 no
gas cars so yes i think they were
looking at eli they were like okay those
are selling we're already in the we're
gonna we're already and yeah we're gonna
go bigger here what kind of challenges
have you faced with supply chain issues
well we have seen um a lot of challenges
primarily due to semiconductors i think
we all know the semiconductor shortage
it's getting a little better but i
frankly think it's something that's
going to last into next year and maybe a
little beyond also because the auto
supply chain for the entire industry is
is very global you know as covid moved
around the globe we saw um you know
incidents where you know we would have
part shortages because of that we're
working through that but that was one of
the reasons as we started to source for
our evs we wanted to make sure that as
much as we could we sourced all the raw
materials uh either um in the u.s in
north america or with allies
can we see the car again shantae i love
the two i think the car is beautiful
paint scheme there i love that white top
on it i do too look at the grill why why
not focus on hybrids do it because some
people are still reluctant to get into
the ev market i think i'm really coming
around finally because i just thought
you got to find a place to charge it yes
yes you've got to find a place to charge
it and that seems like a pain in the
butt to do well you know we made the
decision that we were going to invest in
the end game of getting getting to all
electric it's the right thing for the
environment because at general motors
our mission is to create a world with
zero crashes uh zero emissions and zero
congestion and so getting there faster
because if you think about a hybrid
you've actually got two propulsion
systems on the vehicle it's not
efficient we want to move to the end
game and uh and and have products that
people can uh really enjoy because in
the auto industry people want the
segment they want they have to hit
certain price points and so that's the
very strategic portfolio that we've been
developing listen 20 seconds how soon
can people get that car so this vehicle
is going to go on sale uh in about a
year it'll be uh nexo in 23 and it will
be a 24 model year uh and if you're
interested you can go on chevy.com and
calm we're saving your number
maryborough thank you very much thank
you very much great job we'll be right
back